I'm a director for a few companies as
well
the sound Bank I've got a few other ones
as well so I'm actually I'm I'm somebody
let me tell you something I'll explain
to you so that you don't have to ask
questions why would you teach if you're
directing a profitable company because
my my mission is not centered around
money my mission is centered around my
purpose and my purpose is to actually
educate the youth especially into
well-being for me what I would prefer
ideally is to have somebody that can
travel a lot that is international
somebody that is quite busy doing their
own mission so that they don't have to
always be in my head and you know having
that closeness I don't actually enjoy
that close and I think that is quite
healthy for people to have a lot of
space wants to be present in each
other's lives